well finally from us here at noon  several local celebrities are hoping for  a better 2021 like all of us  mgm resorts got some of them together to  send out some new year's well wishes  listen  just want to wish y'all a happy new year  and to all the healthy 2021.  my new year's resolution this year is to  get back on the court  have a ton of fun and hopefully get some  of those fans those great aces fans back  in the stands  we want all of you to know that every  single one of us entertainers is going  to make sure we put on the best shows  you've ever seen this year  also we'll never ever let you forget  just how  important you are to the vegas community  that's wonderful happy new year oh isn't  that great love seeing flurry too  they're going to start playing here in  just a couple  of weeks so that's very exciting